hello freak I feel good now if I
can get a suit from Hugo Boss a couple
of months ago off the rack and this was
like so happy I could just buy a suit
off the rack before I had to have it
made and have to go for a fitting go for
another fitting all that I'm sure if
they looked at the measurements on paper
they're like what the what is it
suta for what is this and I was like
this wide going on wardrobe what is it
you know so yeah I look on the other
side of it you know young guys coming up
maybe they think that's strange like and
asked me don't you do look at the
pictures back and think wow look like
that I'm like no I don't look at I just
look at that and I think wow that was
extreme and what I did and
that's crazy and it's incredible but
does it use my petitions with yourself
like this a little bit sometimes when I
look at those black and white pictures
giant picture of dorian yates and his if
you've got any of those black and white
pictures of man and that's just like
saying there it is that's like you
couldn't really fit any more muscle onto
that frame really you know no ink i know
i went to places and I did things that
other people you know in the gym look at
your forearms well my there's a
thing for arms I never did any training
for forearms all that was just from
gripping the bar when I was doing back
training mainly and and some bicep
training and stuff 19-inch forearms and
I didn't do a single exercise
for them apart from gripping onto get
that it's so ridiculous well that's a
good picture but it's not me keep going
to your right no no down where you were
yeah go to your right one more that one
bamsae triceps Jesus cry it's from
onstage picture from mr. Olympia so what
you can see if you look on the legs you
can see the thinness of the skin and the
like un sativa the muscle underneath
like there's no fat there's no water
between the skin layer and then the
muscle layer what a body but what
percent of body fat
get down - well I don't really know
because I had skin fall calipers used to
do the same for calipers and they're not
accurate
they used to get down to like 3.5
probably like a month out but I know I
got leaner after that but they didn't
really register because they're not that
accurate after that point so I don't
know maybe three percent but it's you
know nobody measures your body fat it's
what you look like it's a visual thing
it's really what you look like in the
mirror but how did you know like how
much water to drink and when to back off
and experience I didn't really see your
legs dude I don't restrict water
intake until like maybe 24 hours before
the contest look at your right leg there
that's preposterous
yeah that's a huge medialis right over
the knee there yeah that's a lot of sick
work man that's like that's like I used
to train legs pretty much once a week
and for four or five days of every week
I had trouble sitting on the toilet I
had trouble moving around I mean if I
didn't I wouldn't be happy man I have to
feel that pain pain in the ass
pain in the leg just to sit down
but hey satisfying because you know
you've done some damage right if
it's like that and the damage repairs
itself to get slightly bigger and
stronger bodybuilding is just an
adaptation to stress you know you put a
certain stress see buddy's going to
adapt to it I need to get bigger
and stronger so I can handle this stress
next time
that's basically what it is so
continually trying to stress yourself
like anything like you want to get
better cardio got it stress your cardio
system so it adapts yeah there's no
other way right to get that big I mean
there's no shortcuts there's nothing you
can do there's no easy route well I
don't know it looks like guys are
looking for the easy route now because I
don't see them training that hard but
then you don't see the quality of their
physiques the guys are big now but you
look at the quality it's not the same
it's not the same okay not the same
Keeney was generally accepted in
bodybuilding that the nineties was the
peak of competitive physiques as far as
the standard and the depth of the
standard there was like six to eight
guys on that stage that were like really
like if you're off you know there's
places for change
now you've got one guy Phil Phil Heath
who's mr. Olympia and it's pretty like
distance between him and the next few
guys now what is it though that I mean
is it doesn't it open the door for a
current modern-day Dorian Yates like
some super dedicated person mean
physiologically people can still do the
same things that you did yeah but things
have changed since the nineties there's
a lot more avenues that people could
choose to go down as like doing a sport
or I mean for instance UFC didn't exist
right in the early 90s I remember
watching the first show on it was in New
York I watched on TV the first the very
first one you know with the boys Gracie
so you got you got MMA you've got a
CrossFit and you've got all these other
competitions now in in the in the
bodybuilding arena that's not
bodybuilding it's men's physique whether
we're the board shorts and the good have
the nice physique and abdominals a kind
of physique that most write or aspire to
have I guess you got classic
bodybuilding so you got a lot of
different avenues and I think the
interest in pure bodybuilding is a lot
less than I mean in the 90s everyone
wanted to be a bodybuilder it was like
hugely popular
yeah what's interesting now what is this
Jamie what are you pulling up here this
is a mr. Olympia from 1996 as myself
Sean ray in the middle and that's Ronnie
Coleman on the end who became an
eight-time mr. Olympia guys are at Jack
also it's so hard to tell see I'm like
I'm looking at this and my kind of
like well it's also got to be
hard for that tiny dude that's next to
you you know dude has always been
unhappy because it got Ben by me but
thing is he had a great physique just
like Frank Zane had a great physique
right you know if he was the same size
as Arnold maybe he would have beat him
but he wasn't the same size as Arnold
and Brian goes throw the gentleman there
mr. Shawn right he had a great physique
but it you know how much twice as big so
a big guy always baits of the good
little guy right now yeah
[Applause]
[Music]